hi this is Mario with Mario's math
tutoring coming to you with another math
video to help you boost your score in
your math class improve your
understanding and hopefully make math a
lot less stressful so in this video
we're going to talk about is how to
multiply binomials okay and we're going
to talk about the foil method but we're
going to talk about some other methods
too so binomial by means to write so by
only means two terms and then times
another binomial that has two terms so
there's a couple different ways to do
this I'm going to show you a couple
different ways so the first way is we're
going to make a rectangle like this okay
this is sometimes called the box method
and what we're gonna do is we're gonna
find the area of this entire rectangle
or box okay and the way we're going to
do that is we're going to say this
length is ax and this length is 2 this
length is 2x and this length is negative
3 so you can see X plus 2 2x minus 3 the
area of a rectangle is the length times
width so that'll give us the area of
this entire rectangle but what we're
going to do is are going to find the
individual rectangles and we're going to
add them together to get the total area
so you're with me so far
okay so x times 2x is going to be 2x
squared because 1 plus 1 is 2 right you
add the exponents x times negative 3 is
negative 3x 2 times 2x is 4x and 2 times
negative 3 is negative 6 now when you're
finding the area of a rectangle see this
is negative 3 this way to this way so
that's the length that's the width
that's how we're getting the area of the
individual rectangles now if you add
them all together you want to combine
like terms 2x squared 4x and negative 3x
we can combine those that gives us
positive 1x and then minus 6 so this is
our final answer and it represents the
area of this rectangle and it also is
the product meaning you know the two of
these binomials multiplied together
alright so another way to do this
problem is to do the distributive
property so what you can do is you can
take this ax you can distribute so
that's 2x squared you can distribute the
X to the negative 3 that's negative 3x
you can distribute this 2 to the 2x
Forex and you can distribute the 2 to
the negative 3 that's negative 6 now if
you combine these together you get 2x
squared plus X minus 6 which is the same
thing we got there so really what you're
doing is you're distributing the X and
then you're distributing the positive 2
so it's like doing the distributive
property twice okay now the last
technique I'm going to show you is the
foil method and the foil is just an
acronym for first outer inner and last
it just helps you to remember what to do
but what you're going to do is you're
going to take the first term in this
first group so this x times the first
term in this group so x times 2x this is
2x squared then you're going to do that
oh that's the outer now out are the ones
towards the outside so that's x times
negative 3 which is negative 3x I is in
or I'm going to do the ones towards the
inside the middle 2 times 2x which is 4x
and then owl stands for laughs we're
going to do the positive 2 that's the
last one in this group times a negative
3 that's the last one in this group
that's negative 6 if you add them all
together you get the same thing so pick
a method that works for you you can use
the foil method rectangular box method
or the distributive property whichever
way you find easiest but let's go ahead
and do this next one this next one I'm
just going to go ahead and we'll do the
foil method because that's a popular
method with students so first terms I
take first and first that's 12x squared
outer I think about the ones towards the
outside that's negative 7 times 3x now
you want to make sure you capture that
minus sign that's a negative 7 okay
times 3x is negative 21 X inside I'm
thinking the middle ok 4x times 1 which
is 4x and then the last term's that's
the last in this group last in this
group 1 times negative 7 is negative 7
I'm going to combine like terms the x's
are like terms are the same so that's
going to be negative 17 X minus 7 and
12x squared
and I've written it in descending order
2 1 0 so you can see the exponents are
going down that's considered standard
form or descending order so subscribe to
this channel
check out some of my past videos I've
got some more videos like these coming
to help you in your math class go ahead
and comment below if you have some
suggestions for me on how I can make
these videos more helpful for you and
I'll see in the future videos I'll talk
to you soon